dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir simulating the
behavior of water and other fluids is
something we have been talking about in
the series however we are now interested
in modeling the interactions between two
fluid interfaces that are potentially
made of different materials during these
collisions deformations and topology
changes happen that are very far from
trivial to simulate properly the
interesting part about this technique is
that it uses graph theory to model these
interface changes graph theory is a
mathematical field that studies
relations between well different things
the graphs are defined by vertices and
edges where the vertices can represent
people on your favorite social network
and any pair of these people who know
each other can be connected by edges
graphs are mostly used to study and
represent discrete structures this means
that you either know someone or you
don't there is nothing in between for
instance the number of people that
inhabit the earth is an integer it is
also a discrete quantity however the
surface of different fluid interfaces is
a continuum it is not really meant to be
described by discrete mathematical tools
such as graphs and well that's exactly
what happened here even though the
surface of a fluid is a continuum when
dealing with the political changes an
important thing we'd like to know is the
number of regions inside and around the
fluid the number of these regions can
increase or decrease over time depending
on whether multiple materials spit or
merge and surprisingly graph theory has
proved to be very useful in describing
this kind of behavior the resulting
algorithm is extremely robust meaning
that it can successfully deal with a
large number of different materials
examples include merging and wobbling
droplets piling plastic bunnies
and swirling spheres of goop beautiful
results if you liked this episode please
don't forget to subscribe and become a
member of our growing club of fellow
scholars please come along and join us
on our journey and let's show the world
how cool research really is thanks so
much for watching and I'll see you next
time